Das ist wirklich eine Hammer-Meldung: Forschungsteams
weltweit entdecken immer mehr neuartige Riesenviren,
die sich an der Grenze zum Leben befinden.
Normalerweise sind Viren ja auf einen Wirt
angewiesen, um zu existieren.
Sie müssen also fremde Zellen kapern, um
sich zu vermehren.
Doch die mysteriösen Riesen-Viren sind nicht
nur so groß wie Bakterien; ihr Genom enthält
überraschenderweise auch die Bauanleitungen
für die Proteinbiosynthese.
Nur eine Kleinigkeit fehlt dem Riesenvirus,
um sich selbstständig zu vermehren wie ein
echtes Lebewesen!
Ihr habt uns bei Whats App auf dieses Thema
aufmerksam gemacht - vielen Dank
für diesen wirklich spannenden Vorschlag
aus Eurer Community und herzlich willkommen
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Bie uns gibt es täglich faszinierende Science
Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
auch nichts.
Sie sind einfach nur riesig: Ihr Körper ist
durchschnittlich 450 Nanometer lang und daran
hängt zudem noch ein 550 Nanometer langer
und 450 Nanometer dicker Schwanz.
Und das macht sie zu den größten bekannten
Viruspartikeln überhaupt!
Die Rede ist von den sogenannten Tupanviren.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Frankreich hatte Proben
aus einem alkalischen Salzsee in Brasilien
und ebenso aus der Tiefsee vor der brasilianischen
Atlantikküste entnommen und dabei diese Riesenviren
aufgespürt.
Sie hatten Amöben befallen, die ihnen als
Wirt dienten.
Die Analyse unter dem Elektronenmikroskop
enttarnte dann ihre enorme Größe und “den
längsten Schwanz, der je bei einem Virus
beschrieben wurde”, so einer der beteiligten
Forscher, Jonatas Abrahão.
Einige Viren erreichten sogar eine Länge
von 2,3 Mikrometern.
Doch nicht nur das.
Das wirklich Außergewöhnliche an diesem
Virustyp ist sein Genom.
Denn das enthält die Bauanleitung für den
gesamten Prozess der Proteinbiosynthese.
Und das ist wirklich ein Novum in der Biologie.
Ein Organismus gilt nur dann als Lebewesen,
wenn er sich selbst vermehren kann.
Konkret passiert das durch die sogenannte
Proteinbiosynthese, bei der - vereinfacht
gesagt - in Zellen neue Eiweiße gebildet
werden.
Bisher war klar: Dazu sind höhere Organismen,
aber auch Pilze und Bakterien, in der Lage.
Viren dagegen brauchen Wirtszellen, um sich
zu vermehren.
Denn sie selbst besitzen weder die Gene noch
die Ausstattung, um Proteine selbstständig
herzustellen.
Und so gelten Viren eben auch NICHT als echte
Lebewesen!
Bisher… Doch diese Annahme ist so vielleicht
schon bald komplett überholt.
Denn Forschungsteams haben in den vergangenen
Jahren schon mehrmals neue Viren entdeckt,
die sich nicht an dieses Schema halten.
Dazu zählen beispielsweise die Riesenviren
namens Megavirus, Klosneuviren oder Panoravirus.
Allesamt sind genauso groß wie Bakterien
und ihr Erbgut ist ausgestattet mit viel mehr
Genen als man es bislang von Viren kannte.
Konkret enthält die DNA der Tupanviren bis
zu 1,5 Millionen Basenpaare und bis zu 1425
Gene, die Proteine kodieren.
Damit ist es das viertgrößte Genom eines
Virus’, das bislang bekannt ist.
Sie enthalten die Bauanleitungen für Enzyme,
die alle 20 Aminosäuren bauen können und
bis zu 70 Transport-RNAs.
Alles unabdingbare Faktoren für die Prozesse
der Proteinbiosynthese und damit ihrer eigenständigen
Vermehrung.
Und das alles ist auch für die Forschungsteams
eine große Überraschung.
Denn all das zusammengezählt, ähneln sie
sehr den echten zellulären Organismen!
Nur eine Sache fehlt und das sind die sogenannten
Ribosomen.
Diese zellulären Gebilde treiben die Proteinbiosynthese
an; fungieren also als Katalysator.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
stehen vor einem großen Rätsel.
Denn wie genau sind diese Zwitter aus Viren
und Bakterien entstanden?
Möglicherweise haben sie sich aus normalen
Viren entwickelt, die aber mit der Zeit Erbstücke
aus ihren Wirten übernommen haben.
Eine weitere Möglichkeit wäre aber auch,
dass ihre Vorgänger zellulär waren, dann
aber ihr Innenleben wieder reduziert haben?
Die letzte Version erscheint zumindest bei
den Tupanviren als wahrscheinlicher.
Denn um als Zellparasit optimal zu existieren,
war es eventuell wichtig, die eigene Zell-Ausstattung
auf ein Minimum reduzieren.
So könnten ehemals größere Organismen Teile
der Proteinbiosynthese und auch der Energieversorgung
gekappt haben.
30 Prozent des Tupanvirus-Genoms ist jedenfalls
noch unerforscht - es ist also mit weiteren
Überraschungen zu rechnen.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu in Zukunft verpassen
wollt, dann abonniert Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Real Food made
by Sun and Light - A Solution to Global Hunger?
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!